we've all seen the clip of a barow
employee trying to fight Shane Gillis
are these your office workers say your
order make sure this office worker isn't
trying to fight me right now but this
next clip is the story of one of their
workers trying to him I was trying
to pull him at one point and uh I found
yeah I know wait like how did that how
do you go about that um so I uh
developed the crush on him and then I
saw him like three times in one week and
I was like oh I got to rail it in but it
was just like by she was like going
coincidence and um I talked to him after
one of his shows in Austin and I was
like we really just hit it off I went up
to him with the Bud Light he went up to
me with the blood light then I found out
that he broke up with this girlfriend
through friends and uh I I tried sliding
in the DMS and it wasn't really working
did he read it oh no we went back and
forth whoa for a second how long ago was
that um like a couple months ago I dm'
him like 3 weeks ago no didn't even open
this isn't Shane's first rodeo with
barol people wanting to get physical for
example